è da tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video sono fa dj ed oggi siamo sul
secondo speciale quello dei 300 mila
iscritti
dovevo riprendere fiato volevo veramente
ringraziarvi per questo traguardo anche
se l'altro giorno vi ringraziato per i
250mila non me ne frega niente ve lo
ripeto lo sfinimento cercherò sempre di
divertirvi nel migliore dei modi vi
giuro mi impegnerò al massimo per farlo
perché vi meritate di tutto per quello
che state facendo quindi grazie
veramente di cuore ragazzi spero di
avervi commosso con questo discorso
sdolcinato perché è stata tutti
piangendo vero e direi ragazzi che
possiamo iniziare con invito allora
premetto che questa è una cosa che mi
avevate chiesto sin da quando avevo
aperto il canale ma non l'ho mai fatta
per paura che non andasse come
l'aspettativa infatti in questo preciso
momento mi sto pagando addosso perché
non l'ho ancora registrata sopra
registrarla e non so come andrà voglio
provare ad incontrarvi singolarmente il
chart tipo con la webcam infatti ragazzi
quando vi ho chiesto consiglio su
facebook su sta cosa mi avete risposto
che esiste un sito chiamato amico e come
avete scritto nei commenti dove
praticamente si può scrivere una una tag
e tutti quelli che hanno quella targa si
possono incontrare qui i ragazzi di
vecchio ci siamo possiamo mettere come
interessi comuni la nutella perché non
c'è nessuno che non ama la bella se tu
nolani guardati bene le spalle amico mio
perché ti vengo a cercare o c'è ragazzi
dovrei esserci siete un catino porca
[ __ ] aspettate un attimo
devo scrivere nutella nutella perfetto
la cosa è alquanto strana ciao amico mio
non ti sento china webcam a non un
microfono estranee niente come vuoi
salutare qualcuno la nonna al cane di
nicolò che vuoi svetta cent aspetta
aspetta aspetta
[Musica]
6 caldissima calma calma turno per
matera prendetevi bello se il telefono
fermato il telefono ragazzi sta
progettando un attentato
prima mi abbia fatto spaventare a morte
adesso mi fotografa lillo che lavori con
accigliati blog
il video di j
un grande mi fa morire dal ridere
parte forte la nonna e tutti e la
dinastia avete così perché siete siete
anche voi overnight auser chi non diamo
ormai ha ben inizio nel cielo quindi
sono a posto
ciao mamma mia ragazzi mamma mi ha
operato già belle fanno questa cosa
ragazzi e fantastica per abbracciare dei
beni che abbraccia mi presento anch'io
il mio gatto questo mio gattino di
comino ti piace e benissimo e felice di
vederti ciao si felici di vedermi potrei
essere un fake
questa è la è la domanda che tipo rai
per il resto della tua vita non piangere
una cosa veramente dura da credere ma lo
so
no no non chiedere aiuto non chiede
aiuto è una domanda alla quale devi
rispondere ma non riesco a parlare
perché sei emozionata s'emoziona andiamo
annuncia un ciao me lo fai un ciao
ecco la grande
non mi piace per il gioco perché ci
vuole tempo a si aspetta 7 aspetta
aspetta mi mette in posa quella come
aspetta aspetta aspetta fermo lì fermo
licenza una lente amico qui presente
come stai e tutto a posto mi sembra un
mese chris euro non sembra troppo vegeta
tipo che adesso vedo il tuo livello
bomba dov'è dov'è il kamikaze o mio dio
mio dio
anche papa dietro il compagno fan
aspetta aspetta fa la foto aspetta che
gli mette in modo in modo serio
ora so che nel video direttamente a ok
perfetto allora mi metto a fare cose
normali
questo poi condividerlo nei prossimi
documentari su come si evolve la scimmia
ho trovato justin bieber e non sei fa e
non fa vj che delusione
ebbene credo cazzo è vero che poi
trovare justin bieber e non fa vj ma
scusa sai già che toccano il tuo cane
mio fan sì allora ed oggi j l'attenzione
dove doc ejei dove doc igieniche
assolutamente voglio tochigi adesso
voglio chi fa il suo dovere da segugio
ma ora questa festa animale inutile è
fantastico perché non pensavo era come
ciao tutto a posto
cos'è assassin's creed di lollo version
6 microfono microfonino ci faccio alle
ragazze bravi a quello ho detto ragazzi
40 stance aver usato i movimenti
sensuali funzionali sto cercando da un
ora stai tranquilla stai tranquilla
tranquilla tranquilla rilassati sospira
no sei tranquillo no no no no stai 3
mandai tremando come le lezioni di yoga
e di respirazione confavi jalifa così
etica ok
vai ok perfetto ragazzi ma perfetto io
io non posso essere più orgoglioso mi
seguirà tanti ma c'è una catena
padova 6 fallo anche tu guarda pavic
[Musica]
laboris che freddo fa in terra de rossi
ha di sé gradi e temperature gradevoli
ca un saluto marziano fammi un saluto
marziano
ecco vai vai la sfera ma non c'è poi ci
crede neanche la mia foto perché perché
poi vigente così brutto ti ricordavo più
bello perché perché bello e brutto come
stai
da posto è tutto ok ben 5 si fa se la
scultura è una scultura che cazzola
tosatto leggilo leggi quello lo leggi
quello vedi cosa c'è scritto non ti ama
nessuno ormai mai una foto pena foto
ritrovati comprarmi un chilo di carote e
poi no no non fare così kg di carote lo
prendi a parte poi prendi un chilo di
pane a un chilo di riso un chilo di diva
mario mi sono fatta da donna sono venuta
riprendermi tutte le vite che pure tolto
beccando le trappole
io credo che voi due abbiate qualcosa da
cui discutere è vi lascio soli ciao ciao
ciao attacca l'orcia ucciso tutte lì con
le volte ha beccato netta quale ci deve
ridare tutte le stesse vite che ci ha
tolto quel maledetto strano no ho mai
detto
la utility senso
l'acquario papa allora è questa non è
una cosa normale quando dici che devo
vedere la televisione quindi esco vedere
niente
i cani che scatta la foto scattata la
foto
io potrei tentare il suicidio da un
momento all'altro induce mia fare il
contrario dimmi tu chi sei fatti vedere
tua se non ragazzo che dà la possibilità
re di sicilia mi ciao come stai e morta
è morta è morta tutto a posto
l'ance vispa stai tranquilla sei
tranquillo tranquillo controllare che ti
c'era addirittura grazie mille troppo
cento quanti complimenti esageratissimo
va bene grazie mille 6 fantasmi chiudi
video col telecomando la webcam ciao
ciao hai trovato come vj smesso tre
quarti d'ora trovare scusami scusate in
tantissimi cerca di capirmi siete in
troppi ci ho provato a fare più veloce
possibile che c'è il cane dietro l'altro
dopo un altro ad oggi j
sono fatti beccare subito grazie siete
comunque entrambe averne parte dagli
occhiali ma riconosciuto sarete presi in
pieno da will come state
terzo impresa vana tre ore che
aspettiamo
la scusa è certo è la gente che sa cos'è
quello yogurt e patatine ti sei messa a
girare unico e con lo yogurt e le
patatine allora volete lasciare qualche
ringraziamento speciale
pensavo volesse ringraziare lui visto
che mettiamo nessuno fai schifo
ciao a tutti ma dei ragazzi direi che
può bastare per oggi mi sono divertito
un casino peggiore e fantastico farò
sicuramente a tre episodi su di questo
perché sono epici però visto che me lo
chiedeva te tanto per questa volta ho
deciso di fare un qualcosa di
completamente diverso che mi è piaciuto
ragazzi fate quello che volete lasciato
mi piace e condividete su facebook fate
quello che vi pare
siete liberi comunque ragazzi
l'importante è che vi siate divertiti e
noi come al solito ragazzi de vito è
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook che come lo
divido trovate nella descrizione severi
city scrive tilenius li vediamo lucro
servito per ragazzi
[Musica]